effectivement le cours de l'Agau se
porte bien depuis déjà 2 2 3 ans euh ce
qui est ce nous ça nous satisfait
complètement en revanche c'est dû à
plusieurs problèmes à la fois
conjoncturel avec le le brexit au
Royaume-Uni la faiblesse des importation
qui se néozélandaise qui était liée à à
à une sercheresse sans précédent donc
tout ça a fait que la rareté du produit
a fait monter le prix de l'agneau
français et et c'est tant mieux euh
c'est pas pour autant qu'on n pas
soucieux notamment des accords de libre
échange et particulièrement celui qui
vient d'être conclu avec la
Nouvelle-Zélande voilà alors on sait
très bien que les contingents
aujourd'hui n'étaient pas remplis hein
puisqu'ils le sont pratiquement qu'à 50
% mais il n'empêche que la
Nouvelle-Zélande a des possibilités de
réactivité que nous n'avons pas à des
prix qui sont qui arrivent quand même à
deux fois et demi moins cher que
l'agneau français et que de suite ça a
un impact sur les cours forcément donc
oui les éleveurs sont inquiets et puis
sur surtout qu'on a l'impression d'être
dans un autre monde on comprend pas on
comprend pas quand on voit l'Union
européenne afficher une décroissance
pour l'élevage à hauteur de 30 % pour
les années à venir et qu'on importe
davantage de viande où est la cohérence
dans tout ça est-ce qu'on nous dit à
nous Français ne produisez plus on va en
importer davantage euh voilà quoi donc
vous comprenez que ça aussi c'est
difficile à comprendre par les les
éleveurs que nous sommes quoi on se dit
mais mais mais à quoi on joue quoi